So here's a cool psychological study,
so it's called the marshmallow test and
maybe it's even a reliable study.
Even though it was done by social
psychologists,
it's probably replicable and it's a nice
study.
So you take small children and you bring
them into a room and you put something
that they would like in front of them,
a marshmallow and you then you torture
them.
Basically you say,
see that marshmallow in the kid thinks,
man,
I see that marshmallow.
It's like you can have that marshmallow
right now or if you wait,
I think the experiment is 10 minutes.
Then you can have two marshmallows.
And so that puts the child in quite a
conundrum because they're being asked to
trade in actual concrete,
tangible marshmallow for two
hypothetical future marshmallows and
it's not that easy to conjure up a
hypothetical future reality that has the
same tangible significance as something
real right in front of you.
And so it's amazing thing that people
can do that.
And so then the experimenter leaves and
some children's grabbed the marshmallow
and just chomp that thing down right
now.
Other kids,
they videotaped kids while they're
waiting and they do all sorts of things.
They whistled,
they look at the ceiling,
they sit on their hands,
you know,
they tried to distract themselves.
Course they're eyeing that marshmallow
like a squirrel lying and not and and
trying to restrain themselves and you
know what I see in that is that the
child's prefrontal Cortex,
the higher cortical systems are warring
with the underlying motivational
systems,
more primordial motivational systems
that govern such things as hunger.
The hunger system,
hypothalamic system says there's
something sweet and fat right?
Sitting there,
right bloody now grab that thing and
stuff it down now,
and I'm sure many of you have a constant
battle with your hypothalamus with
regards to sweet and fat things and
often lose so you can feel some sympathy
for the child,
but the hypothalamus has these
tremendously powerful tendrils upward
into the brain,
into the parts that we would associate
more with voluntary control and the
voluntary control centers have these
little weak ribbons going down to
control the hypothalamus.
Since it's pretty obvious,
if you know something about
neuroanatomy,
what part is actually in charge when the
chips are down,
and it's not easy for children to learn
to regulate those underlying primordial
impulses,
the ones that are wired in,
the ones that we share with animals,
but they do it and and,
and the cool thing is,
this is what Walter Michelle found.
He's the guy who did the study,
was that the longterm outcome for the
children who can delay gratification in
the marshmallow test is much more
positive than it is for the children
that are impulsive and eat the
marshmallow instantly.
It's delay of gratification.
Now it's likely that that's associated
with trait conscientiousness,
although that specifically has that
specific connection has not yet been
established,
but they seem conceptually very,
very similar.
So.
So anyways,
this emerges in children probably
between the ages of two and four,
something like that.
They should have it in place by four
because it's very difficult for them to
really interact well with other children
without having that delay of
gratification in place.
Because if you can't delay
gratification,
other kids don't like you because
you're.
You want everything your way and you
want it now and you're.
You're liable to temper tantrums and
that sort of thing.
You haven't got the kind of self control
necessary to make you fun to play with
so you can see that emerging in children
and it's pretty.
It's pretty interesting and not only
that,
if it emerges,
it predicts positive longterm outcomes
just like trait conscientiousness does
by the way,
because trait conscientiousness is the
second best predictor of longterm
success over the lifespan.
In Western cultures,
it's second after intelligence and so in
our societies,
the people who do best across time are
the people who have high Iq is and who
work hard and I would say that's a
pretty decent,
what would you call it?
It's a validation in some sense that our
cultures are working properly because
what you would want,
I would say if the system is working
meritocratic Lee like it should,
and if you're trying to extract
resources from those who can contribute
at a higher rate than what you would
want to have happen is that the hard
working smart people do better.
Hopefully.
If that's the case,
then everyone does better.
Hopefully.